un autre chantier qui est en cours c'est
celui du Cher oui son niveau est très
bas en ce moment à tour vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué alors pas
d'inquiétude ce n'est pas à cause de la
sécheresse il a été mis au chômage pour
trois semaines il s'agit d'un
abaissement volontaire du niveau de
l'eau réalisée par tour métropole afin
de faire le grand nettoyage annuel des
infrastructures reportage d'Aurélie
Renaud
régulièrement le petit groupe de
marcheurs de Tours Nord se rend sur
l'île Balzac depuis quelques semaines il
s'interroge sur le niveau très bas du
Cher là vraiment il y en a pas beaucoup
c'est et pourquoi pour le nettoyer ah
d'accord mais c'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise chose ah c'est eux qui l'ont
descendu d'accord pour faire le
nettoyage j'ai pas compris ça du tout
comme ça d'accord ok la mise en chômage
du Cher c'est un abaissement volontaire
de l'eau l'abaissement permet un grand
nettoyage effectué par propulsion de
glace carbonique ou grâce à des karcher
notamment sur les ponts alors ça permet
de d'entretenir nos infrastructures
alors pour le Cher sur Tours c'est les
deux barrages de Rochepinard Legrand où
on est présent et le petit et c'est
aussi la rivière de contournement on
retrouve moisissure on peut trouver des
branches et tout un barrage amovible
avec des clapets est installé sur le lui
aussi est nettoyé et inspecter il doit
rester en parfaite état afin d'être
actionné à tout moment en fait on a on a
un règlement d'eau donc c'est un
règlement qui est négocié avec l'État
sur le sur le niveau du Cher qui nous
demande de maintenir toujours la même
altitude sur sur le plan d'eau sauf que
et ben il y a des périodes où il y a pas
d'eau dans le Cher et la période où il y
a beaucoup d'eau dans le Cher donc il
faut qu'on s'assure que quel que soit le
débit de du Cher et ben on est toujours
la même altitude ces opérations
orchestrées par tour métropole
permettront également d'inspecter les
différentes passes à poissons elles sont
situées en amont de la rivière de
contournement où se déroulent les
entraînements de canoë kayak le parcours
lui aussi sera nettoyé